on this Saturday night the province by
province reopening closed down because
of Cova 19 which businesses can restart
and the rules to do it there is great
concern that we're hearing about opening
too soon why some medical professionals
say wait
rebuilding Fort McMurray flood recovery
in a pandemic Plus why Australia and New
Zealand have been successful in battling
the new coronavirus and Canadian
reinvention it's all about you know what
we are doing to try to get ready for
tomorrow the traditional business model
takes on a new twist
[Music]
global national would Robin Gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us Canadians have been waiting weeks for
koban 19 restrictions to the east with a
close eye on preventing a new surge in
cases provinces are beginning to take
their first cautious steps to do that
the situation is improving in many parts
of the country but some places are still
grappling with rising numbers overall
there have been more than 56,000 cases
of Cova 19 since the outbreak began more
than 3,500 people have died some good
news in New Brunswick which hasn't
reported a new case of Kovan 19 in 14
days and today that government says all
of its 118 confirmed cases have
recovered making it the only province
without an active case but it's a
different story in Quebec which
confirmed more than 1,000 new cases in
the past 24 hours and 114 new deaths
still that province is pushing ahead
with plans despite concerns it may not
be ready our Mike Lakota takes a look at
the road to reopening across the country
imagine the frustration of a child it's
the first nice day of the year and the
playground is still off-limits
I think they missed that you know get on
the swings and the monkey bars and all
that kind of stuff so that's hard there
those won't be opened yet in Ontario but
other restrictions are being relaxed
garden centers and nurseries can start
curbside pickup on Monday and more
businesses will be allowed to reopen as
long as they maintain health guidelines
we see the trend going down and we just
wanted to continue going down we need
consistency for a couple weeks and then
we can loosen things up a little bit now
other provinces are already loosening
things up Quebec will be the first to
reopen elementary schools as early as
May 11th Manitoba is relaxing measures a
little quicker with some retail stores
restaurant patios and hair salons
allowed to welcome customers again as
long as they maintain physical
distancing now Alberta is moving in that
same direction considering opening some
businesses starting May 14th in an
interview on the West block with
Mercedes
Stevenson premiered Jason Kenny said the
key to reopening is to keep the number
of hospitalizations below what the
health care system can handle my view
and that of our officials is is that we
we cannot eliminate the risk of the
corona virus what we have to do is to
manage the risk there are concerns part
of that risk include restarting work at
the Cargill meat plant in High River
Alberta after a two week shutdown it's
the center of the provinces largest
kovat 19 outbreak the United Food and
Commercial Workers Union has launched
legal action to stop the reopening amid
fears it's not safe enough for employees
production and the medical community is
worried the entire country might be
reopening too quickly
that we didn't have enough testing out
in the community to really get the good
data the information that we need to be
able to open safely so there is great
concern that we're hearing about opening
its and soon provinces say they're going
to continue moving forward understanding
that another spike of kovat 19 would
mean they'd have to shut things down
again michael accretor global news
Ottawa in the u.s. more than 30 states
are in various stages of easing
restrictions and with warmer weather on
the horizon health officials are once
again warning Americans to take
precautions as Jennifer Johnson explains
the country's top infectious disease
doctor says a second round of kovin 19
is inevitable a massive protest in
Huntington Beach California demanding
business's beaches reopen with tempers
flaring a street brawl erupted an
example of just how divided America is
of a returning to normal too soon for
restaurant owners in Texas serving
customers again couldn't come soon
enough there was a time where I was
losing thirty thousand dollars a day and
you know it's not huge but that's a lot
of money if you're not ready for it
White House officials are hoping
businesses reopening will jumpstart
America's crumbling a
the Trump administration will now
monitor how each state is doing before
giving more financial aid we're waiting
to see what the economic impact of the
gradual opening up is assessing you know
what that does to the demand for say PPP
loans these small business loans members
of Congress looking for answers will not
hear from the nation's top infectious
disease expert next week the White House
has blocked dr. Anthony Fauci from
testifying in the house which impeached
u.s. President Donald Trump but will
allow him to testify before a Senate
Health Committee May 12th
now he has often clashed with President
Trump on reopening the country too soon
you can't just leap over things and get
into a situation where you're really
tempting a rebound that's the thing I
get concerned about so far no state has
met the federal guidelines to reopen a
decrease in Cova 19 cases for 14 days
but the economic toll of the pandemic is
weighing heavily on Americans
federal officials reporting in almost
900 percent surge in calls to its
disaster distress national helpline
they're faced with complete annihilation
if you will and so being able to at
least start up business again is going
to relieve a tremendous tremendous
amount of strain during the weekend
President Trump has left the White House
for the first time since late March the
president's focus now operation warp
speed
pushing researchers to create a vaccine
to prevent cope at 19 as quickly as
possible
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
in Fort McMurray tonight residents are
seeing firsthand the damage done by
flood waters this week an ice jam along
the Athabasca River caused a sudden rise
in water forcing 13,000 people to flee
their homes globals Brianna Carsten
Smith is in Fort McMurray as residents
return Brianna this is what so many
front yards in downtown Fort McMurray
look like right now for the first time
residents are getting a chance to see
the damage from the flooding this
weekend the damage is extensive in one
case a resident tells me he thinks he
had about 8 feet of water in his base
many people saying they're not even
bothering to try to save anything
because it is all just too waterlogged
but in one case we spoke with a man who
found a box of trinkets from his time in
the military
happy finding in a time when he needed a
little bit of hope we're hearing two
main things from people on the streets
mostly that they didn't have enough time
to prepare none of these homes were
protected by sandbags they say they
weren't given enough warning the second
thing we're hearing is that they do not
think they're going to get any help from
their insurance companies many people
could use a bit of financial help right
now this is a region so reliant on oil
and oil prices are dropping rapidly also
they're impacted by Co vid 19 many
people laid off or have lost their jobs
and this comes at a time when people are
still reeling from the Fort McMurray
wildfire four years ago on Sunday so
this is an anniversary that is hard to
mark right now and a natural disaster
once again Fort McMurray is cleaning up
from Brandon Karsten Smith's
global news in Fort McMurray as
floodwaters begin to subside around Fort
McMurray cleaning up will just be half
the battle for residents the Cova 19
pandemic remains a threat and infectious
disease experts warn this could be a
risky time as Heather Yorick's West
explains the community needs to stay
cautious as it tries to pick up the
pieces 18-year old Hannah wallowski had
planned to spend the summer isolating
with her family in Fort McMurray I was
in Kelowna for University for my first
year and then came back in late March
just be with my family through the
pandemic but when water began to fill
well aus Keys childhood home those plans
changed
I'm staying with one of my really good
friends and then my parents and the dog
are staying with one of their good
family friends to have the flood on top
of what's happening with the cool that
is is really horrifying in some ways
Alberta health officials have put
measures in place to reduce the risk of
an outbreak evacuees have been put up in
hotels and motels instead of crowded
shelter spaces but it's when the water
recedes and people return to clean up
that the risk of an outbreak may start
to rise people are just gonna
say screw it we need to get this done
anyway or I mean and some people will
mere masks and stuff and try and
maintain their distance but at some
point what's more important in 2013 when
flooding ravaged southern Alberta the
community of High River rallied to help
their neighbors social distancing wasn't
a concern this time around anyone
wanting to lend a hand will need to take
precautions I think when you cannot
maintain the physical distancing this is
where those other measures come in as an
absolute critical defense dr. Jenny says
volunteers will need proper PPE he also
recommends people be restricted to
bubble zones so that if an outbreak
happens it stays contained and testing
testing will be key given the the risk
of an outbreak we need to be sure we're
in there testing people regularly
and not just people with symptoms the
good news is there aren't many cases of
kovat 19 in the region right now experts
say it will just take vigilance to
ensure it stays that way Heather your ex
West Global News Calgary a Royal
Canadian Air Force flight safety team is
in Italy tonight they're there to
investigate this week's deadly
helicopter crash off the coast of Greece
the cyclone helicopter crashed into the
Mediterranean Sea on Wednesday six
military personnel from HMCS Fredericton
were aboard the chopper when it went
down during a NATO exercise five of them
are missing and presumed dead the body
of sub-lieutenant Abigail Cobra has been
found yesterday the crew members held a
vigil to pay their respects any human
remains that are recovered will be
repatriated to Canada next week a
powerful earthquake has struck Porto
Rico the 5.4 magnitude quake hit near
the southern part of the island it
briefly knocked out power and damaged
several buildings and businesses there
are no reports of any deaths
today's earthquake comes just five
months after the u.s. territory went
through another powerful tremor which
destroyed hundreds of homes and caused
millions of dollars in damage North
Korean leader Kim jong-un has made
first public appearance in nearly three
weeks on Friday he cut a ribbon to mark
the completion of a fertilizer factory
near Pyongyang state media video shows
Kim walking talking and smoking during
the ceremony he had been seen in public
since April 11th sparking rumors he was
seriously ill or even dead coming up the
secret to the successful Koba 19 fight
in Australia and New Zealand
the biggest shipment of personal
protective equipment to come into Canada
so far arrived in Montreal last night on
a chartered flight from China the
shipment is believed to contain mostly
protective gowns for health care workers
it arrived on the world's largest cargo
plane an Antonov an-225 that plane can
carry up to 250,000 kilograms of cargo
now let's take a look at the global
pandemic picture there are more than 3.4
million confirmed cases of Cova 19
around the world the virus has claimed
over 240,000 lives more than 65 thousand
of those deaths are in the US followed
by Italy with close to 29,000 but the UK
is on track to overtake Italy
it added 621 deaths today bringing its
total to over 28,000 France is planning
to extend its health emergency by two
months until July 24th its government
says relaxing measures prematurely could
cause another spike in cases all
travelers to the country will also face
a compulsory two-week quarantine period
runners cyclists and pedestrians crowded
onto streets and paths across Spain
today it's the first time in seven weeks
that people in that country are allowed
out for exercise Spain's government has
set up time slots for age groups to
prevent crowds from exposing at-risk
elders this week New Zealand and
Australia also relaxed some of their
lockdown measures both countries have
been able to quickly and sharply reduce
the number of kovat 19 cases and keep
deaths low Redman Shannon takes a look
at how they did it and what the rest of
the world can learn
New Zealand's proud cafe culture is back
Kiwis saw rules loosened on Tuesday
after a month under one of the world's
harshest lock downs that included the
closure of almost all businesses and
strict quarantine measures for anyone
entering the country the strategy paid
off with a low infection rate and a very
low death toll community transmitted
cases have been all but eliminated the
country set ambitious goals for contact
tracing in an effort to mirror early
successes achieved in South Korea and
Taiwan yes we have done that in lockdown
the goal now is to keep up that work so
we're now in the next phase of the
battle and we are not done Australia's
had a softer lockdown but as seen a
similar fall-off in cases on like New
Zealand restaurants were allowed to open
for takeout and the iconic Bondi Beach
reopened two surfers this week that was
beautiful
like it's so good to be back in the
water like we've been planning for it
for since the beach was closed in
addition to the lockdown measures both
countries benefit from their remote
location which gave them more time to
react if you saw your first case later
than other countries you've got more
time to plan and more time to see what
other countries respond and what they
did right to rock in fact they started
their lockdowns down under after Canada
New Zealand Prime Minister Jacinda ardor
and has been widely praised for her
clarity in contrast to the initial mixed
messages in another island nation I was
a hospital the other night where I think
there were a few there were actually a
few created virus patients and I shook
hands with everybody not to mention the
confusion that rains after White House
briefings the disinfectant where it
knocks it out in a minute one minute and
is there a way we can do something like
that injection inside any crisis the key
to success is always being clear and
decisive and unwavering and I think
that's what New Zealand showed being
consistent and acting fast summed up by
this warning from the
w-h-o back in March perfection is the
enemy of the good when it comes to
emergency manager speed Trump's
perfection however it could yet be years
before we know who really made the best
calls Redman Shannon Global News London
still ahead a princess offers some real
treats to help in the pandemic the royal
family is celebrating the fifth birthday
of Princess Charlotte daughter of Prince
William and the Duchess Kate and to mark
the occasion they've released new photos
of her helping the most vulnerable in
this pandemic the images taken last
month show Charlotte delivering food
parcels to the elderly who lived near
the Royals Sandringham Estate Boris
Johnson and his fiance Kari Simmons have
named their son
Wilfred Lori Nicholas Johnson he was
born on Wednesday and one of his middle
names is a tribute to dr. Nick price and
dr. Nick Hart they both treated the
prime minister when he fell ill of Cova
19 in March up next reacting by adapting
the Canadian innovations emerging from
this pandemic I don't have anything
super interesting prepared for you I
just thought that I would pop in and
phone this thing in the way I phoned in
my final year at Kitsilano secondary
school
that's how actor Ryan Reynolds kicked
off his commencement speech delivered
virtually to the grad class of the
Vancouver high school he attended he
topped it off by having his favorite
local spot deliver 385 extra large
pizzas to every grad and the teachers by
the way the BC born actor graduated from
the school in 1994
Kovach 19 has shuddered so many
businesses across Canada for now and for
good but sometimes when one door closes
another opens
as the pandemic spotlights the urgency
for innovation Mike Armstrong looks at
how Canadians are adapting they wanted
to keep selling vehicles at this Alberta
auction house physical distancing meant
they had to find a new way of
doing it while they're doing it now
without people what was once the most
important thing for an auction house you
know one of our larger events upwards of
15,000 people registered online Ovid 19
closures left performer Martin Kurt
without anywhere to perform bars have
shut down festivals are being cancelled
but instead of sitting at home Kerr and
his manager put outward he'd take gigs
just about anywhere request started
flooding in and we've got about 20
booked already I think all over the city
disruption is occurring everywhere Jim
Carroll would normally be on a stage
somewhere talking trends he's a
futurologist instead he's working out of
his home delivering speeches from a new
studio Carol says kovin 19 is driving
urgency to innovate it's all about
attitude it's all about mindset it's all
about you know what we are doing to try
to get ready for tomorrow whether it's a
B C trainer who's moved online or a new
production line at a Quebec company
making hand sanitiser
Canadians are innovating I was like okay
one that Carol's following is an Ontario
farmer who'd normally be selling at
farmer's markets instead in a matter of
days he created a virtual market and
distribution system for himself and
other producers I'm running my farm like
I'm growing food I'm growing even more
food right now then I had planned to
this year Carol says what innovators are
doing is adopting instead of sitting
back and that this era will leave a
legacy five or ten years from now we're
gonna look back at this and go like that
was really a massive breeding ground for
innovation and creativity that was
simply unparalleled Carol may make a
living predicting trends and where
things are headed but he says right now
in the present he's having trouble
believing how quickly things are moving
my curbs on global news Montreal and
that is global national for this
Saturday I'm Robin Gill we leave you
tonight with this life-sized game of
Monopoly chalking up fun in Edmonton
it's the work of five neighbors hoping
to bring people together outside while
staying apart good night
[Music]